a new week and a new round of testimony
from the witness stand in the Alec
Murdoch murder trial why some of the
jurors were dismissed from this
high-profile case plus what a DNA expert
had to say about evidence found
underneath a victim's fingernails that
could be a win for the defense you can't
really tell you how or when the DNA got
there lawn crime daily covering court
cases from coasta coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber and thanks for joining
us new information about the presence of
DNA underneath Maggie Murdoch's
fingernails could be a pivotal
Revelation in the murder trial against
her husband disgrace South Carolina
attorney Alec Murdock DNA from an
unidentified male was found underneath
her fingernails after she and her son
Paul were found shot to death at their
country estate now Paul and Alec were
being excluded as the contributors but
the analysis couldn't really go much
further because there wasn't enough to
really create a DNA profile DNA analyst
Sarah Zapata was just one sled analyst
to testify Monday on cross-examination
the defense wanted to hammer home that
there could have been another person at
the scene but Zapata explained it's not
that simple
were you all aware as we've had the
previous testimony that Maggie Murdoch
had been to a nail salon late that
afternoon
have any information about that no so if
her nails were quite clean coming to
Moselle she doesn't have a lot of
opportunity to have contact with
unrelated males that's fine
overgrowed the objection
so if her nails were clean coming to
Moselle
it doesn't appear that she has much
opportunity to have that kind of contact
with unrelated males does it
it could be DNA you know DNA under
fingernails you're picking up DNA
anytime you touch an item potentially
um if she did get her nails done it's
possible that
somewhere at the nail salon there was
DNA that she picked up under her
fingernails so you can't really tell you
how or when the DNA got there but at any
point in time between getting her nails
done and arriving home she could touch
an object and potentially DNA from that
object could be under her fingernails or
she can touch an individual and their
DNA be under her fingernails in that way
and the Drummond in there you see judge
Clifton Newman started Court by
announcing that two jurors had to be
released from jury service because they
tested positive for covid-19 the judge
gave the jurors the option of wearing a
mask in court but didn't make a
requirement he also encouraged others in
the courtroom to mask up two alternate
jurors are going to be part of the
regular panel which leaves three
alternates left over another was
dismissed earlier on in the case the
defense suggested pausing the trial for
a few days but judge Newman decided that
the trial will continue for now let's
get some perspective from Terry Austin
Brian buckmeyer Terry two jurors tested
positive for covet if another juror
tests positive I'm thinking possible
mistrial here what do you think I'm
thinking that could very well be
possible we've seen it but it doesn't
happen very often in the Danny Masterson
case you may recall that a couple of
jurors were dismissed because of covet
and in that case they just sent two more
in and that was during deliberations I
don't think we're going to have a
mistrial here first of all it's not
during deliberations and all of the
jurors and all of the alternates have
heard all of the evidence so we still
have three more alternates to go and
it's possible that one or two Miller may
have covert or may get covered but the
judge did say they were tested on Monday
and they're going to be tested again on
Wednesday so he's basically just taking
it day by day he's not calling any big
you know mistrials well let's not even
put that in the air uh Brian sled agent
Zara Zapata testified there was
unidentified male DNA under Maggie's
fingernails that felt like a big win for
the defense and it was Jesse and I think
the defense could have done a little bit
more to shore it up her explanation of
how DNA got under Maggie's finger and as
I could have didn't seem very clear to
me I mean you just sat down on the table
where Bob Bianchi was sitting not too
long ago so you probably have some of
Bob's DNA on your hand but probably not
enough for her to register like
something under the fingernails I get
what the defense is trying to do maybe
she fought her attacker and that
person's DNA is under their fingernails
they also got out of this witness that
they did not compare that DNA to CODIS
the National Database to see if this
person was a convicted felon or who this
unidentified male was I think that could
raise Reasonable Doubt whether or not
it's enough to avoid this conviction
that's another question Brian you lost
me and I had Bob's DNA all over my hands
now I can't think about anything else
but the show will continue and I'll tell
you what if you want to keep up on the
latest on the Murdoch murder mystery
it's all on longcrime.com we have links
to live streams Court exhibits and of
course expert insight
[Music]
and welcome back everybody we're
bringing you the latest out of Broward
County Florida in the murder trial of
rising rap artist xxxtentacion a
cooperating witness continues to testify
against his three alleged accomplices
and the attorney for one of hip-hop's
biggest names is fighting to keep his
client far away from this case the
victim's real name is Jose onfroy he was
20 years old when he was gunned down
during a robbery at a motorcycle
dealership in 2018. prosecutors believe
defendants Michael Boatwright and
Trayvon Newsom carried out the attack
and a third co-defendant Diedrich
Williams drove the getaway car at the
scene a fourth co-defendant Robert Allen
took a plea deal in exchange for a
possibly reduced sentence and part of
that deal has him landing on the witness
stand for several days we also reported
that Aubry Graham also known as high
profile rapper Drake will have to appear
for a deposition later this month you
see defense attorneys argued that he's
tied to a possible conspiracy to kill
onfroy because because they had an
ongoing feud at the time of his death on
Monday Drake's attorney appeared in
court arguing against the singer being
associated with the case altogether
at this point I think you have a
cooperating witness that corroborates
that Mr Graham has nothing to do with
this case there's Mr Graham is not
listed in any report Mr Graham I don't
believe has been discussed whatsoever in
this case to my knowledge other than
um groomer and innuendo and I believe
that it's if I was hired earlier I would
have probably filed a motion to quash
that deposition itself because like I
said there needs to be some good faith
showing at least you know his phone was
in the area he was in the State of
Florida at the time there's some sort of
communication there's something and
there is absolutely no evidence
whatsoever other than rumor in new I
know we felt that the defense raised at
least
you know through what he said uh
the barest
level to allow for Discovery you know we
have wide open Discovery here
um this is a first degree murder case
defendants are facing potentially life
in Florida State Prison and uh before it
doesn't want to be in a position that at
some later point they say well what for
having taken this deposition
so let's do it all over again
so now the question becomes what will
the defense ask Drake in that deposition
while we spoke with trial attorney and
former Judge vanon Rucker to find out
what we can expect
the exploration of the relationship
between any of these four folks and
anybody associated with Drake's Camp so
they're going to be asking about who his
producers were who his connections are
and this part of the part of the country
who may be connected to who they're
going to be doing an FBI type
um board with everybody's pictures and
strings and and letters and numbers
matching with different hoods and
Families
so Sarah you've said that Drake
shouldn't be forced to testify in court
but what do you think about him being
forced to submit to a deposition well
you heard the judge there he thinks that
he wants to avoid any sort of appeal
issue but I agree with Drake's attorney
look this is rumor and innuendo he
should not have to come to testify there
is nothing connecting him to this crime
having said that I do think if he's
ordered to go he should just go he
should answer the questions the last
thing he wants to do is to be held in
contempt for something that he has
nothing to do with right now he can go
in he can answer the questions he can
say it wasn't there and he will be
relieved I think and it will avoid him
having to come to trial because at that
point the judge can say not necessary
okay Brian seems by all accounts he's
going to be deposed he deposed he
answers all the questions then what
happens I don't think we're even gonna
hear or see what Aubry Graham or Drake
ends up testifying to because I think
this is a fishing Expedition or a better
way of saying it the defense is just
shaking every tree to see what falls out
I I think it's ridiculous to think that
a person's rap lyrics can somehow have
them forced into a court to answer silly
questions that could have easily been
examined through like the defense
attorney for Drake was suggesting
um where was he at the time of the
murderers where what was his
Communications I think we're going to
see I don't know yes I was here I plead
the fifth I don't know this and I think
at the end of the day we get this
deposition and neither side sees any
relevance or any reason to actually
input it into the case I think the the
judge already gave it away I just want
to cross my my T's and Dot my eyes and
make sure that this doesn't come back on
appeal because we never did it I think
they do it it's a waste of time and we
move forward with the case see I think
it's just for the defense showing that
investigators didn't look at all of the
theories I don't think it's really
suggesting Drake did it but hey how come
you weren't questioned by any detectives
I think that's maybe where they might be
going but we'll wait and see so let's
actually turn to another hip-hop case
this one out of Atlanta where jury
selection slowly continues in the Ricoh
trial of rapper Young Thug and his
alleged gang young slime life 14 people
face gang-related charges including two
murders of rival gang members jury
selection started in early January and
has been constantly interrupted by
courtroom mishaps most notably several
incidents of drug Contraband being
smuggled into the courtroom and there's
even been issues with the potential
jurors themselves one person didn't show
up for jury duty and in order to avoid
prison time the judge forced them to
write a 30-page essay on why jury duty
is important most recently a potential
juror was held in contempt over
contacting a reporter about the status
of jury selection now the judge spared
them 20 days in jail by ordering 10
hours of community service speaking
about the subject of behavior choices
and consequences they're also going to
have to attend the first five days of
the trial once it's starts